- hello and welcome everybody to the h3
podcast today's episode is sponsored by
honey and expressvpn today I am joined
by Mick West's video game developer
turned skeptical scientist was that
right right a scientist and debunk our D
bunker would like to use author of
escaping the rabbit hole how to debunk
conspiracy theories using facts logic
and respect which is available on Amazon
and host of tales from the rabbit hole
podcast thank you very much for being
here thank you for having me I
understand you flew here from Sacramento
so were you able to confirm that the
earth is flat on that airplane
it did look flat out of my window but I
was able to measure it you haven't it no
I have actually done that though I've
taken a little little spirit level out
and you can use it to look out your
airplane window and measure the the dip
of the horizon it's that easy
yeah it's it's a little fiddly because
the horizon is all hazy when you're up
in there and this guy but you can
actually tell that the earth is a sphere
from that's a lot easier than what these
guys went through you saw the Flat Earth
documentary on that flurry I'm assuming
those guys went through a lot more
effort than just hopping on a plane yeah
well they think that those reasons why
you know plane is plain view is not
correct like some of them think that the
plane windows because they're curved
they make the earth but there's so many
easy ways you can you can check this
wasn't that you find it so funny that
somehow the excuses are more believable
to them oh yeah yeah they'll jump
through anything any they'll do all the
mental gymnastics in the world
I find it wasn't it just so amazing
though how they disprove themselves
continue to disprove themselves in that
documentary first would like the
gyroscope they're like don't tell
anybody
yeah then finally with the the laser
test yeah and the more the more rigorous
the experiments they do the more likely
they are to disprove themselves and then
the more layers they have to put on top
of that to name the conspiracy it's
incredible how
I mean how is it that in this day and
age of science wouldn't maybe maybe
almost we have too much information it's
an information overload but it seems
like the more information and science we
have available the more people are
willing to look past it well the flutter
that's gonna come from a position that
science is any real it is something that
you can verify yourself which is not
entirely unreasonable position to come
from you think like why should I trust
all these scientists don't trust
hundreds of years of history and all
these books and what they taught me in
school but then they think that they
should be able to figure out for
themselves what the shape of the earth
is but they kind of overestimate their
abilities the reason we have all these
scientists figuring things out is that
some of the stuff is actually fairly
complicated some of the stuff like you
know how much of the horizon dip when
you go up he doesn't actually dip very
much anything like two degrees or so and
they they kind of expect it in you know
from there they're feeling about the
earth that it would be this huge curve
visible plane but if you do the math
which a lot of them don't do and you can
see it's not very much so they don't
draw scientists they trust themselves
but they don't really they're not really
able to follow through on it interesting
and well let me ask you this first
before we get too deep into this what
you you've committed your life to so far
I mean you were you were a successful
video game developer you retired and you
went into became a debunker so why is
this something that's so important to
you initially I wouldn't say it was
super important to me it was just
something I did for fun I really enjoyed
doing it I like investigating stuff
looking stuff and I was always really
into like like ghosts and UFOs and stuff
when I was a kid yeah and even into my
teens you were a believer at one point I
wasn't I would say I was a believer but
I just found the whole subject really
fascinating things like spontaneous
human combustion
it's like these mysteries how did they
actually happen and just when I got
older I started getting into the science
and I started reading a lot was a
popular science books and that's really
the combination of those two things
could have led to my interest
in essentially debunking conspiracy
theories you can figure out why
spontaneous human combustion actually
happens and why they find you no bodies
burnt in in rooms and you can figure out
what people are seeing when they're
seeing UFOs like I do a lot of UFO video
and now assists and things like that so
I I just really enjoy picking stuff out
but I do feel like it's become an
important thing to do because I think
yeah false conspiracy theories can
actually hurt people and that bad but
for society but for everybody
everybody's like you know acting on the
basis of these things that are false
right and it's it's not good so I feel
I'm doing some good and I'm also helping
individual people who get stuck down the
rabbit hole have you have you found that
you've actually been able to bring
people out of the rabbit hole because I
know it seems like you can see from the
documentary people are willing to delude
themselves pretty much to a never-ending
degree yeah definitely and yes you can
bring people at home there's been people
that I've talked to in the past who are
now no longer down the rabbit hole and
here they say in part that's because of
it because you talk to me or because you
showed me this information but for
everybody it's usually quite a long
journey you talk to a friend who
believes in some you know conspiracy
theory like chemtrails or 9/11 being an
inside job or a controlled demolition
and even if you show them a few things
you know show them where they're wrong
they're not gonna like flip their
opinions right away
yeah and they might not even do it like
in the next few months he conserve them
some people that can take years there's
a guy in the book that I interviewed and
for him it was it was like it was many
years between him falling for the
chemtrail conspiracy theory and then
eventually figuring out that it was
wrong so you you I'd say that there
certainly is hope for everybody no
matter how far gone they seem because
some of these people were really totally
all the way down the rabbit hole they're
believing in like you know aliens and
shapeshifters and things like it's like
yeah I mean by the way you can if you
speak directly into the mic that's
helpful you can move it so you kind of
like I find that it's almost like when
people get this kind of paranoid
thinking it's like you you you you
mostly will buy one if you buy one you
buy more than one yeah it's kind of a
paranoid thinking but so when you pull
people out of this rabbit hole do you
find that it has positive consequences
on other aspects of their life yeah well
I think it really it strips away the
negative consequences that people have
in their life like they're living in
fear a lot of the time right and they
feel a lot them tell me that it feels
like a great weight has being lifted on
them when they finally figure out that
these things were not true because they
were living under the you know the idea
that the government is this powerful
evil entity that does all these plots
and controls everything and everything
you see in the media is false and if
somebody can believe that the exaust
targeting them personally and when they
eventually figure it out yeah a lot of
them they don't you know they don't come
entirely out of the rabbit hole but they
lose their greatest fears when they
think you know they're finding other
chemtrails are not poison being sprayed
in the sky and they figure out that 9/11
was you know just al-qaeda and then it
allows them to focus on other things so
okay here's what I want to do before we
get into some of the more popular
conspiracies I thought it'd be
interesting place to start with proven
conspiracies because I I do it now I
want to acknowledge on one hand that
there are such thing as real
conspiracies and I think the existence
of some of these helps fuels
it helps feel the paranoia in people's
minds being like well that was true yeah
well this can be true too so I want to
go over some of the more notable ones
and get your take on it mate maybe you
can clarify but but like for example
MKULTRA I'm sure you're aware of the CIA
was testing LSD on unknown participants
to see if they could make Soviet spies
defect against their will or if the
Soviets could do that to CIA agents who
were captured that was the goal yeah and
the seat the CIA was administering LSD
to people without their consent or
knowledge to study the effect they even
at times set up fake broth
fools and lured men in from the general
public and then dosed them with LSD and
experimented on them the reason it being
a brothel is because they figured they'd
be too embarrassed to talk about it
after
afterwards in one case they administered
LSD to a mental patient in Kentucky for
174 days several people died as a result
of MKULTRA most notably Frank Olson as
CIA employee one of their own who was
covertly dosed with LSD held for study
and then six days later committed
suicide when somebody wasn't properly
supervising him he jumped out the window
so this is the kind of thing that you've
look at you say oh god the government's
capable of that mmm then of course
they're capable of
you know chemtrails yeah I think you got
a look at the actual scale of things and
also look at the historical context
during this was back in was it the 60s
yes that it happened and you know it's
the height of Cold War right there's
lots of fears about things there was
there were other things as well similar
to that like they they tested the
dispersion of biological weapons and
giving them weapons by by spraying them
in places but when they did it they
weren't doing it with the intent of
harming people or trying to you know
actually infect people they were just
trying to see in a safe way what the
effects would be now that were you
talking about there sounds pretty bad
like especially you know using mental
patients mm-hmm how do I know exactly
how accurate that is but the the story
about Frank Olson that's true and
there's some suspicion that he was
actually thrown out the window
rather than jumped because he was
becoming very erratic after he it was
involved in this study and he kind of
knew afterwards what had happened but
they he was acting very strangely and
they thought he was going to blow the
whole cover and I'll talk to the
Russians about it or something like that
and so there's some suspicion that he
might actually have been thrown out the
window so she's a conspiracy yeah that's
against fear and so do you when you hear
something like that are you do you think
it's credible when you hear like oh well
I mean in the in the scope of what there
was sure why why wouldn't it be credible
well you guys think were criminals yeah
but in the chemtrails conspiracy theory
is on such a completely different scale
the idea all the planes that we see on
the side for the last you know 70-plus
years wanna say since the seventies say
have been spraying of with some kind of
chemical and that and no one's ever come
forward to say or it is impossible no
one speaking it down yeah and all the
evidence that people give for this thing
is it's completely ridiculous I the fact
that the CIA did bad things in the
sixties and seventies everybody in
everybody knows that the CIA was like
almost like a rogue organization and
they didn't what a bad things they did
false flag operations in foreign
countries so you know yes we know they
did these things but compare like with
like don't just say like you know they
dosed some people that means they're
dosing people now they did some
controlled experiments that were like
very limited in scope on a small number
of people most of whom were actually
volunteers and then they did some some
stuff that was very immoral and it
wouldn't obviously didn't plus passed
the clinical test standards but it's a
completely different thing braum
everybody in the united states is being
sprayed with something poisonous the
skit yeah I see what you're saying I
mean obviously that was a small-scale
thing did the CIA come forward with that
information or was that something that
was unveiled through investigative work
the the MKULTRA they yeah they had house
hearings on it that can't force them to
release the information I think there's
just been a big info dump of documents
being released for your documents on a
cycle the black vault the guy just got
like thousands of pages of documents
today like all the stuff oh wow the
ultra this was just I just saw a tweet
this morning so wow it's gonna be
interesting yes any new comes out
alright but I wanted to follow up just
to kind of show like kind of what the
government is capable of doing in a case
like this after he committed suicide or
was murdered possibly the US government
first described it as a suicide then as
a misadventure so they're they're
they're removing the blame from
themselves and in effect and nobody
really knows another one that would that
was just apps
insane I think you alluded to was
radiation testing on the US public
during the Cold War here just like for
example in San Francisco they would uh
pepper in radioactive activity into the
rolling fog yeah not sure if that was
actually radioactive there there's a
thing called zinc cadmium sulfate yes
here's the thing they use which isn't
really radioactive it's fluorescent it
means you know if you shine a and
infrared light now all true pilot light
on it it will glow so it's a thing that
you can you can track very easily and
the reason they use it wasn't to see how
well radioactive stuff spread it was to
see how well excuse me how well powder
spread hmm because they figured Lena the
the Russians or whoever would be like
you know spraying stuff into the air how
much of San Francisco whatever would eat
actually get through and to do that they
need is something that they could detect
very easily mmm so they used this zcs in
commune sulfate we thought was perfectly
safe time it's not like some strange
radioactive stuff it's just stuff that
you know glows in the dark when you when
you shine a light so they could they
could detect it very easily they I don't
know whether you had like a little
little detector of glowing specks or
something but it was that's why they
used that I see so they thought it was
safe but it wasn't cuz I heard I had
read that somebody there was cases of
known cancer as a result know a thing
about you know people say that cases of
cancer some things you can always find
some kind of correlation between any one
thing and cancer like if you live near
power lines people will say you can find
a correlation between parallels it's
always gonna be like hot spots here and
there there's always going to be some
people who attribute their cancer to
something there's no real proven court
engine correlation between this release
of zinc cadmium sulfate and and that and
it's something this please pretty safe I
mean you wouldn't want to be eating
teaspoons of it hmm
but a little bit of it sprayed in the
air probably wasn't going to hurt
anybody do I think they likened it like
the effects of one secondhand smoke like
being in room with somebody whilst they
smoked a cigarette or like less than
that here's a big one that we all take
for granted the NSA surveillance the
scope of that before it was leaked was
something that none of us could have
ever imagined what was taking place so I
think the existence of that is probably
a fuel to the fire of a lot of
conspiracy theorists that the US
government spying on citizens of pretty
much of all level of detail in fact this
is one my favorite anecdotes that
Snowden revealed he says in the course
of the daily work they stumbled across
something that was completely unrelated
to the work for example an intimate nude
photo of someone in a sexually
compromising situation situation or but
they're extremely attractive he said
what do they do they turn around in
their chair and show it to their
coworker and their co-worker would say
hey that's great send it to bill down
the way they considered it perks of
their job yeah that's terrible as well
as the the NSA in the government spying
on American citizens like they do as
much as they can get away with sure they
want to have as much information as they
can they're constrained by the law but
they're also constrained by how much the
law is enforced like they're supposed to
get a FISA warrant right for four people
but they didn't have sealed warrants a
lot of the stuff that was revealed was
stuff like the metadata for phone calls
like they would record every single
phone call you made not necessarily
record the actual voice they do have the
capability of recording all the voice
and looking at it later
which is something that they they're
arguing that they can use that to get
around they you know the laws against
recording because if no one listens to
it right it's just a very buffer
essentially then yeah so you know I
wouldn't trust the NSA oh yeah I don't
trust the government and I I don't think
people should trust the government
interesting and I think that you know
when you hear about things like that and
the Snowden's revelations you know
that's something that we need to you
know look at them we need to have checks
and balances in place and we need to
actually work to try to stop things like
that happening so where does a healthy
distrust of the government and an
unhealthy distrust of the government
begin well it's when you start believing
things
really aren't backed up by the evidence
when it's just kind of a suspicion of
something and the thing you're
suspicious of is something that is very
outlandish and would require a very very
large operation like for example the
buildings that collapsed on 9/11 some
people say that they were rigged with
explosives so that they would collapse
from explosives after the planes had hit
them now that isn't backed it really by
any evidence at all people say this
evidence but when you look at the
evidence they present it's really really
bad terrible evidence and the theory
itself doesn't really make any sense you
have planes fly into the building's big
hole in them huge fires that went on for
four hours
and then the buildings collapsed on the
fire and everybody in engineering
community ladies they collapsed because
of the fire mm-hmm so now you've got
these other people coming along and
they're saying oh no it was explosives
and it must have been explosives it
looked really weird like blacks look
really weird mmm but there isn't really
any strong evidence for it so you're
coming up with a you know distrust of
the government but it's it's it's a
ridiculous thing it's very enough saying
like you know the government does evil
things people in the government do evil
things and the government is lying to
the people a lot of the time you know
most of the stuff you seen coming out of
the the White House is PR essentially it
isn't really just them trying to let you
know stuff that's good you should
actually have that distrust of the of
the government but it doesn't mean that
every anti-government Theory is
automatically true you got to actually
look at is this theory actually
undeniable theory right there's there's
one more you know this one I thought I
think a lot of people hold this to be
true I certainly did but when I started
looking into it
it seems that reports of it are very
contested that the CIA was trafficking
crack and cocaine in the 80s to help
fund some of their campaigns and they
were largely responsible for the crack
epidemic and in black neighborhoods you
that's kind of a multi-layered one
really like the people yeah they said
they were selling drugs for guns mm-hmm
or drugs for whatever they were doing to
finance their operations which and I
know I'm not I'm not sure if this does
true it was there's evidence
apparently in 1986 a spoke met
acknowledged that funds from sales of
cocaine smuggled into the u.s. had
helped fund the Contra rebels but said
that smuggling was not authorized by the
US government or resistance leaders
right yeah I am not really familiar with
that one so I couldn't tell you then
there's the broader conspiracy there
that they deliberately sell sold crack
in black neighborhoods to you know
impoverish them yeah yeah just keep keep
black people poor essentially which is
you know obviously yeah
pretty serious pretty outraged yeah
they're a yeah and yeah I don't know if
there's any real evidence behind that
you know they would sell it in
neighborhoods where crack had been sold
before I would imagine yeah I don't know
if they had any kind of conscious
pushing it into certain neighborhoods
well let me ask you this are there any
proven confirmed conspiracy theories
that are favorites of years that come to
mind
well yeah there's this very obvious
conspiracy theories that that are true
conspiracies that would sure like
Richard Nixon lying about Watergate
right you know we all know what happened
now we in great details we know exactly
what happened and by the time he was
denying it and half the country thought
that he wasn't lying and if you did
surveys at the time do you trust Nixon
on the Watergate issue and they they
believed him and that turned out to be
here the conspiracy there was true but I
think there's a huge range of
conspiracies that happen all the time
we live in a country where in a world
where there's a lot of corruption
there's a lot of corruption and there's
a lot of graft there's a lot of light
you know you pat my back up at yours
like you know you'll do something for
you he does something to me favors
people conspire to do things and the one
I always come back to is just simply
politicians doing things for industry
essentially the military-industrial
complex that we have we have the the
government makes regulations industry
doesn't like regulations that will
prefer certain regulations so industry
lobbies the government to try to get the
regulations a certain way they don't
just lobby though they give campaign
contributions to politicians they give
gifts to politicians and at some point
it kind of sets over the line from
giving these gifts to actual essentially
bribery and people are being convicted
for this it's not really you know a
conspiracy theory that it happens we
don't know exactly who's doing it really
get caught but we know that this is
actually happening
we know that industry is essentially
buying Congress to make favorable
regulations for them and that's the type
of very serious conspiracy that I think
that people would be much better off
focusing on I mean right yeah I mean the
consequence of that is as big as
anything else that the that people are
paranoid about you know yeah and another
of my favorites along those lines is the
prison industrial complex prisons
for-profit prisons they're trying to
make money yeah yeah and so they will
lobby the government for regulations and
laws that will make them more money
which means they do things like trying
to increase mandatory minimum sentences
hmm and so they're essentially bribing
politicians to like boost the laws boost
the sentencing laws so people have to
spend more time in jail for the
essentially harmless offenses and a lot
of them are just like we yeah we'd
nonviolent yeah yeah yeah that's it
that's another great one I think the
fact that prison is related with profit
just seemed so well wrong the there's
more prisoners in the United States than
any other country including you know
China with billions of people all right
the stat is like here per capita per
thing one percent of the u.s. population
is in prison is all right yeah about yes
I mean that's three million people that
is absolutely amazing and it's just this
kind of constant thing and it really you
know it took off with the the war on
drugs so a lot of these people are just
essentially drug offenders but
they don't really have a very good
support system so you get I'm going to
jail and they're coming out and then
they forget some other petty offense and
now they're in the three-strikes system
so they go back for another 20 years or
something meanwhile they're all opioids
are being prescribed to everyone you
know the real world that's right by
pharmaceutical companies to get people
addicted to the drugs yeah I is it a
conspiracy it's not really a conspiracy
there it's just a fact they're trying to
sell a dress and they want people to get
them says it it's up to the government
right to regulate them and it's them to
sell as much drugs as possible yeah if
you see a commercial on TV that
essentially is this drug company trying
to persuade you that you need that drug
so many drug commercials - isn't it just
terrifying yeah and it really should be
just you know your doctor should tell
you if you knew that it's not used and
the doctor I got to have this drug they
know talk to your doctor about this new
drug yeah and it's the doctor I mean how
corrupt is the doctor profession where
you can come to them and say I saw this
commercial and I want to try this drug
and the doctor is more persuaded by that
then what you may actually need yeah
it's a messed up system and I think in
other countries they don't allow no
adverts like that I mean coming from
Israel I remember being really shocked
when I saw the commercial break and how
much of it was for dry-time telly it's
like 50% like in Israel I think all you
would see is kind of like advil you know
something for headache over the counter
over in the corner kind of yeah yeah
well that's that that those are that's a
great point you bring up I think it's
it's something that a lot of people
shouldn't bear in mind is like you know
you can spend all day thinking about
chemtrails and anti vaccination in
prison you've got an incredible amounts
of corruption and and in our government
and that's that's more harmful then he
even if their conspiracies were true I
feel like that's inflicting more harm on
the on the populace yeah to a large
degree yeah I mean if you think about
9/11 sure if 9/11 was was true that it
was a conspiracy by the US government
obviously that would be a huge
all thing but it's not actually
affecting that many people right now
another thing that happened for and was
used for propaganda purposes I think you
know it was just as it appears to be and
it's not an actual conspiracy by the
government but you know if it was yeah
why why how is how is your activism in
9/11 going to help yeah I held the world
make it won't it won't really yeah back
to anything but well we're coming up on
are we take a break at 30 minutes and
now now I want to get into these kind of
what I call contested conspiracy there's
the juicy juicy ones and we can talk
about the the details of those you know
Bob Bob Lazar who was really amplified
big time Joe Rogan had him on his
podcast he had seven point six million
views largely persuasive of people who
watch that I want to talk about Epstein
that's just I mean even someone who me
like me who is very not prone to
conspiratorial thinking is the Epstein
thing it makes you wonder right I mean
so let's get into all that we're gonna
take a quick commercial break you guys
know how it is we believe right back
with Mick West stay tuned
ela if you're shopping online without
honey then you are lose literally losing
hundreds of dollars every month during
savings and I don't want to see you do
that because frankly we share bank
accounts we are we shared money and illa
if you're not using honey you're losing
me money ultimately I want to share that
insight with you guys what is honey
honey is a plug-in that shops while you
shop for the best coupon available so
let's say oh I'm on Best Buy and I want
to buy a computer well what's gonna
happen at checkout is honey's gonna scan
the internet for all the best codes
available and apply the one
automatically that's gonna get you the
biggest discount it's free it's easy to
install two clicks and it's basically
like your old cheap dad who sits by the
fire every night clipping coupons not
paying attention you more focused on
saving about $20 then ray giving you a
proper upbringing it's like that except
you're not neglected
as a child and you don't have to live
with the shame of actually sitting and
clipping coupons it's a way it's honey
here for example ela bought some tools
for teddy fresh for designing Pantone
books we literally saved 758 dollars it
was super expensive these books cost
seven thousand five hundred eighty bucks
and with honey where they were able to
find a coupon that saved us seven
hundred and fifty bucks are you kidding
me that's not the only time honey
continues to save me money continues to
impress me it's so easy to install the
average honey user saves a hundred and
twenty six dollars a year that's like a
hundred and twenty-six free King to all
those dude that's like a thousand
Bubblegum's there's no reason not
there's no reason at all not to try
honey it's free it's so easy to install
in just two clicks you're gonna save
money you're gonna treat yourself to
something nice guys just give it a shot
join for free at join honeycomb slash h3
that's join honey comm slash h3 get it
poppin get it rollin start saving and
forget about it
you believe you're not being snooped on
or that nobody cares about your online
data well I'm sorry to disappoint you
but you're wrong because you listen to
my show you're clearly smart enough to
understand that your privacy is under
attack
hackers government ad companies that is
precedes our is PCs are all gobbling up
your data like all of it that's why I
recommend getting the software that I
trust to protect my online activity X
yeah can we get like flames when I say
that I'm lightening their apps use
powerful encryption to secure your data
that's VPN runs in the background of
your computer or phone and then you use
the internet just like you normally
would
you download the app put to connect and
voila you're productive
I never go online without that's proof
and you shouldn't either expressvpn is
the fastest VPN and that ever has ever
been created and it costs less than
seven dollars per month and it comes
with a 30-day money-back guarantee
to expressvpn uses new cutting-edge
technology called trusted server to make
sure there's no logs of what you do it's
time to stop hackers Big Brother the
internet companies from gobbling up your
data
take back your online privacy like I did
without spruce boo boo yeah
and right now protect your online
activity today and find out how you
could get three months for brew
expressvpn Kansai shakes three
that's expr ESS VPN dot-com / 8 3 4 3
months free with a one-year package
visit expressvpn
dot-com / h3 to learn more
[Music]
we are back with Mik West you can get
his book on Amazon escaping the rabbit
hole and you can check him out his
podcast is tales from the rabbit hole
podcast you know Dan just checked the
the fact the stats there are more people
in prison in America than the entire
rest of the world combined yeah it's
pretty amazing monthly we have like a
quarter of the population of China right
India China I mean I mean that's what do
you say about that I mean what are we
talking sometimes I hear stuff like that
and I'm like why are we talking about
Kent Rose okay there's more people in
prison in America than the rest of the
world combined there's three million
people whose lives have been ruined a
lot of them prove their own fault
obviously but a lot of those people who
are in imprison me you know they don't
need to be there yeah well I think of my
you know I think back on my own life I'm
like if any of many of us almost all of
us could in the right place and time or
the wrong place and time be one of those
people you know I've done stupid things
and I've walked around doing it do you
know breaking the law and there's just
it could have happened to any of us in
the wrong place in the wrong time so
well regardless of that let's let's
let's go on to the the juicy stuff shall
we all right so my first question for
you is can fire melt steel beams no it
comes
I can't melt steel beams so they're
right it can soften them enough to let
them Bend hmm like if there was a fire
in a room and there's a steel beam on
the roof usually what will happen is the
steel beam will sag down mm-hmm and that
yeah if you have enough of a fire and
enough of the structure is compromised
especially in something like the World
Trade Center where the structure on one
floor is supporting the structure of
everything above it is if you weaken
that structure you've got this huge
weight pressing down on these beams and
these columns and enough of them enough
of them Bend then you're going to
eventually get a collapse that's what
the Commission found and it seems like
such a great explanation to
firfer like what you saw the way that
the building collapsed it seems to
really explain what happened yet it's
not enough yeah wait it's because it's
actually quite complicated or what
happened like we we're talking about the
fire melting steel beams and people say
why did the entire building collapse if
the fire was only at the top mm-hmm you
know the the building below wasn't
damaged at all it was completely
undamaged so what's the explanation for
that and the thing is the NIST who did
the actual investigation into it they
never really addressed that it never
really addressed in-depth why the
building's fell as quickly as they did
what they did say was as soon as the
building started to collapse there was
no way of stopping it and it just fell
through itself patient basically but
because they didn't do a detailed
explanation of that that's allowed
people to come up with conspiracy
theories and they will say you know that
there had to be some other mechanism on
top of the fire to caused this collapse
because they don't understand how it
actually collapsed because it's quite
complicated hmm so you're saying they
note that the Commission didn't fully
understand how it happened or the
conspiracy theorists don't understand
now the Commission from their
perspective it wasn't the Commission
that 911 Commission will actually
investigate it like the hijackings and
things like that not so much their
collapses it was the NIST report that
did the the investigation the National
Institute of science standards and
technology science Atlantia so they
investigated the collapse up to the
point where the top started to fall
right so they say which core columns we
severed when the planes hit how much did
the plate how how much did the fires
burn what damage did the fires do you
know how would this soften columns how
would the building start to sag the top
was start to lean to one side and at
some point there wasn't enough support
to keep keep the upper floors up and it
started fall and then they said at that
point yeah collapse was inevitable that
everything would just collapse so they
didn't detail it yeah but they knew you
know there are a whole bunch of
scientists and engineers there they knew
that once the top started to fall it
would just go all the way down to the
bottom it was it was obvious but they
it's really explicitly explained what
was happening or why it was so fast and
there's this fella this it's a
reasonably simple explanation as to why
it happened the building kind of simple
analogy would be a zipper and that
you've got something that's very strong
you can't pull apart a zipper sideways
it's quite strong but if you just pull
the zipper down each thing comes apart
you know one one tooth at a time that's
kind of what happened with the World
Trade Center hmm the the outside of the
building is attached to the the core of
the building via the floors which are
very long and the floors themselves are
only designed to support the people
walking around on them and their own
weight plus the safety margin the floors
are not structural elements in terms of
supporting a vertical load so something
falls down on the floor it's very easy
for it to light gonna strip the floor
away from the columns and you've got all
these floors all the way around linking
this licking the core to the outside and
once you've got a falling mass of
girders which weigh hundreds of tons
each falling down from the first the
first drop was only one floor so the
falling down say 13 feet the next one is
26 is falling down 26 accelerated even
further see you can imagine if you drop
a a 20 ton steel girder on top of
something from even just like 30 feet
it's gonna pretty much destroy whatever
was underneath it and you've got
hundreds of these things if not
thousands of them falling all at once
and the whole building is disintegrating
it's pointed pieces it's like dropping a
huge yeah whose bag of boulders on top
of it so it strips away all these floors
from the columns the columns are
unsupported you see the walls the
exterior walls can appealing away almost
like a banana peeling away and these
sections falling off it's because
they're not attached to the core anymore
and they've got this huge mess inside
yeah the chorus of is a lot stronger
than the exterior walls it's really
these very thick columns some of them I
heard like 2 inch thick steel up there
and performance just thick at the bottom
that actually stands a bit longer and
you see this if you watch the videos
carefully you will see bits of the core
remaining whilst the collapse is
happening
easy poking up through the cloud of dust
because the floors have instructed where
the outside walls are falling away but
the core is still kind of standing for a
while it's time for a little bit longer
but eventually like it succumbs to it
and in both buildings when the collapse
wave of the the building you he saw that
people think going all the way down the
building when that reached the bottom
half of the core was actually still
standing the building starts like
listing your full height half of it is
still standing and all four things are
stripped away and you see in some photos
or something they they describe it as
the spire it looks kind of like this
spindly spire but it's really half the
height of the building they've got
stripped away which kind of demonstrates
what the mechanism was mhm so there is
actually an explanation for why it fell
as fast as it did it fell through the
floors it didn't fall through the
columns columns are the strong things
you really hard to fall through a column
but you fall past the columns stripping
away all the support the columns are now
unsupported from the sides very easy to
bend something when it's not supported
from the side yeah that all collapses
mmm there was an explanation there
people just don't don't like to listen I
think it's just it's so spectacular what
happened that not just one one was was
uh was incredible two was just like
overwhelming right and so I think just
the sheer destruction and chance of it
of it happening like that it looks it
was hard to believe it was
incomprehensible to look at I remember
hearing about it I was driving to work I
was on the 4 or 5 and I'd heard on the
radio like someone talking about you
know Washington being attacked and I
thought I'm listening to some play or
something and then I tried changing the
channels and it was the same thing on
there and then someone said a plane flew
into the World Trade Center and I'm on
the phone to my wife at the moment while
this is going on and it's giving me
chills just thinking about it
and then I heard them say one of the
towers has collapsed yeah I was like how
can that be
just then another yeah and then so I
said I was relating this to my wife I
was like one of the towers has collapsed
yeah and then the other one has co-op's
knows yeah it was just your brain can't
wrap around it and I think if you saw it
on TV as well that's gonna be a
even more so it's just this what the
heck is going on here this huge
explosion looking thing for God the
second one hit the building on through
yeah yeah I saw that too so that so
there's other so the other aspect of
conspiratorial thinking around that is
the building seven issue which wasn't a
satellite building of the World Trade
Center right yeah a smaller associated
building it was about half the height of
the World Trade Center towers also
collapsed it also collapse yeah it was
its bet it was about one block to the
north another block on the city block he
was one building away from the North
Tower the North Tower was the one with
the antenna ah
did any other buildings collapse there
were buildings that were essentially so
destroyed he might as well call them
coincidental that the three buildings to
collapse you know you're talking about a
separate building yeah was the world
another World Trade Center building well
the entire complex was essentially World
Trade Center this one was just you know
bit off to the side mm-hm but the reason
it collapsed was essentially that the
North Tower Tower one fell against it
you had this this this tower near the
was 1300 foot tower and you just I think
like 600 feet away
you've got the World Trade Center seven
building seven and the entire south face
of that building is facing the World
Trade Center which is just like a few
hundred feet away and then there's this
enormous collapse with life stuff going
everywhere you know huge clouds of
debris and there's good as flying off
and a lot of that hits the the World
Trade Center 7 and he damaged it quite a
bit there was actually like a large
chunk taken out of one corner the
southwest corner and then there was like
what looked like a whole line perhaps
one whole column had been destroyed it's
hard to sell with the smoke on that side
loads and loads are damage to the
windows so it was very easy for fires to
get started you know there's burning
debris coming down and fires get started
throughout the building several floors
were on fire at least like four or five
floors were fully engulfed in fire all
the way across other floors had various
fires here and there you look at the
south side of the building a lot of the
times the conspiracy theorist will just
show you then show you
the north side of the milling because
most of the people at that time were on
the north looking south mmm because
that's where the safe area was seeing if
people went north on the island so they
show you the south side the north side
of the building which looks relatively
undamaged right the the south side is
completely engulfed in smoke he can tell
how much fire there is but it's the
smoke everywhere and there you can see
damage you can see this huge gouge that
has been taken out of the corner and the
fires basically were unfought for many
hours right I had heard that
firefighters were in building seven but
they were actually had had decided of
act of triage to abandon building seven
and just let it burn so they could focus
on the main towers yeah and there were
reports throughout the day that people
thought it was going to collapse and
people thought that because they could
you could hear the building shifting
right and they could some people said
they saw like a bulge in the side of the
building and then there's one famous
clip of a firefighter saying it's gonna
collapse there's no way it couldn't
collapse so you have all that but then
it's like you just see one dude on the
street like you remember loose change
that was like I remember I was in high
school watching that and it was it was
almost like the cool it was a kind of
hip to be a 9/11 conspiracy theorist
because you were just if it made you
feel kind of like inside and cool and
intelligent and and but what this
documentary shows and a lot of what you
see is some guy on the street near the
there the tower saying like oh it
sounded like a explode like a demolition
or I saw demolition in art a couple of
first-hand accounts but that verse all
of the you know official data and
footage and the counts and that's it
that's all it takes it does yeah people
you think he didn't sound like a
demolition he didn't look like a
demolition for a start the Twin Towers
being destroyed from the top down
there's no demolition using explosives
that does that you know they would they
would trigger it at the bottom we do it
at the bottom
yeah and then it would ya know start
from her
the World Trade Center 7 that looks more
like a demolition that it comes fairly
straight down but the huge difference
between nothing a regular demolition is
that there weren't these loud bangs hmm
if you listen to our actual controlled
demolitions it's incredibly loud and
then like the super super loud bangs
which you can hear from a mile away and
would be would have been recorded by
this little rhythmic and it's and it's a
timed and there's a lot of them yeah oh
yeah they they can do it with one at
once but they generally don't but if
there was just one it would be an
enormous ly loud yeah bang so you don't
hear that so you saying it's like a
controlled demolition yeah it
superficially looks like one the
building comes down but so I mean people
who demolish buildings use the same
principle of physics you have the
building destroy itself under gravity
right here exactly you know it doesn't
help also kind of when you look back on
the politics surrounding 9/11 it's like
all the sudden were attacked by al-qaeda
and the government is like oh we need to
go into Iraq yeah so again the
government
I feel like fuels this conspiracy by I
mean it doesn't make any sense
what is a rep what it erected yeah they
know it was exploited they exploited the
event now they essentially benefited
from it in that it furthered their
geopolitical goals in some ways but just
because that happened it doesn't mean
that they actually did it sure it just
means they took advantage
oh great yeah I mean if you find a
wallet on the street it doesn't mean
that you stole the wallet from somebody
just means you've just found it and you
take it doesn't mean you and if there
was a murder and there's something lying
around and you take it doesn't mean you
killed the guy mm-hm
you're just exploiting the situation and
that's what happening with the
government all right 9/11 you know I
you had tweeted something interesting
before we move on you had tweeted that
9/11 is here it is on the TV fading away
yeah that's interesting yeah interesting
9/11 this is this is the Google Trends
chart and there was a huge peak back in
step 10
2006 which I think was the time of the
the NIST report being released for the
towers collapse and so it was like the
heyday of people criticizing the
government and every year you see a peak
and every year pretty much it gets less
and less and now really nothing yes
almost nothing there's probably going to
be a peak a slightly bigger peak this
year because there's uh the architects
and engineers for 9/11 truth mmm this
this big truther organization they
actually paid the University of Alaska
like three hundred and forty thousand
dollars to do a study on building seven
they have that much fun stuff yeah
people donate the yeah they're they're a
pretty big organization I think they're
taking like a million dollars a year and
the goal again it's like I'm full-time
pay though oh they're full-time
employees and everything that's again we
go back to this issue of like then
anywhere in the world
that's the stat that is undisputable
well I would say you could do both if
this was a real thing mmm but I don't
think it is I don't think it is a real
thing I think they're wasting their time
well I wouldn't like fault people from
doing things that they think to be true
and pursuing something but yeah really
after all these years nothing has really
changed no new evidence has come forward
that's true and we should have been able
to figure it out by now instead we've
just got the same it's a nonsense
evidence being recycled over and over
again people you know saying oh we fill
faster than free for things like that
when they're just ignoring the actual
explanation as to why it can fall not
faster than freefall but at near
freefall speed right accelerations so
you're just getting the same stuff being
recycled over and over again for fast
enough proof for this how is that even
possible regardless it's technically as
possible excuse me it's possible if
something is pulling it in addition to
gravity but how could you possibly
physically pull down the let's say let's
say you're standing on top of a cliff
and you're tied to someone and with a
long rope and they jump off and a couple
of seconds later you jump off
they're already falling faster than you
so the road gets taunt and then that
pulls you down sure but how could you do
that with the bill in a building if the
interior of the building
falls down the core comms are falling
down then when they hit the lower floors
that can pull down on the outside by the
floors kind of pivoting in and pulling
down it's theoretically possible but how
does that how does that and further
their conspiracy desert yeah that's what
I'm concerned about if you had if you
had explosives it would fall
it wouldn't freefall all that yeah
because they would sever everything you
wouldn't have this complicated mechanism
understand that sir it's not a claim
that they make it's actually a deep
bunker claim though some people have
said oh we can if you measure it
carefully it's a bit actually a bit
greater than freefall interesting
therefore it couldn't have been
explosive I am really like verified that
it will make all right let's talk about
Epstein something current all right
something uh as I said I am NOT one
prone to conspiratorial thinking by any
means but when you look at the
circumstance around
Epstein's death it is so questionable
and I'll preface it with this there's a
Rasmussen poll conducted in August found
that 29% of American adults believe
Epstein actually community committed
suicide while 42 percent believed he was
murdered to prevent him from testifying
against powerful people with whom he
associated and 29 percent were undecided
Clinton body count and Trump body count
were trending on Twitter as users
accused both Bill and Hillary Clinton or
Donald Trump of being involved in
Epstein's death and of course our
president several hours after Epstein
was found dead retweeted a conspiracy
theory suggesting that there was a
connection between the Clintons and
Epstein's death so there's a lot to
unpack there obviously let's start with
Epstein's death as you know here's the
circumstance the guy had attempted
suicide a mere week before he was taken
off suicide watch several days before
his death correct me if I'm wrong on
those right he was able to set up a will
two days before his death the video
footage that was supposed to be
recording was claimed
unusable the guards who were supposed to
be watching him were apparently they're
supposed to be checking on him on an
hourly basis did not check on him for
several hours during the period of his
death and and I mean he's one of the
probably the most precious felon in the
American justice system or not Mellon
but the suspect suspect in the American
justice system and yet despite all of
that he was able to die yeah whether by
suicide or murder foul play we don't
know well they claim suicide so how I
mean okay Stu someone who did someone
who's not conspiratorial minded how do
you how does that all that stuff add up
I mean what's your take on that I think
well what I like to do when you
presented with something like this is
not have to go for one explanation or
the other I say I believe this or I
believe this instead I'd like to make a
list of the possible things that might
have happened and then say how likely I
think they are I call it a comic ranking
like ma comes razor see use Occam's
razor but you keep everything in a list
and so you think what's the most
plausible thing what's the next most
plausible thing and you know what
evidence would be needed for this so I
think you know I would put the
possibility that there was some
conspiracy going on behind his death as
being a plausible thing I think the most
likely thing is that he just killed
himself
and I think that what we are seeing with
all the things you just mentioned like
the guards you know not checking on him
the video not working if there was
records falsified the guard said they
went and checked on him but they didn't
and they just falsified the records and
you know all of that just kind of shines
a light on the crappy state of the
federal prison system the federal
prisons are very overcrowded the very
understaffed the people who are stuffing
them are often unqualified these sadly
sometimes even have to have people like
janitors and technicians do some of the
rounds because they have so few people
working there they had reported that
some of the people watching him world
um not officers yeah exactly yeah yeah
so they have like you know janitors like
just doing it because they need someone
decking on to do something it's you know
menial tasks and in the federal prison
system the rate of suicides as doubles
more more than doubled in the last eight
years because there's been this downward
trajectory and in the quality of care
essentially in the federal prison system
and overcrowding and lack of staffing I
think there's something like 2000
vacancies you're comparing epstein
situation to a normal prisoner whereas
he was a suicide risk and he was someone
that was greatly important to the
Justice Department yeah well obviously
no one made a big deal about saying he
should be put on suicide watch
permanently mm-hmm so should that have
been done in hindsight obviously yes is
that part of the conspiracy
well there's kind of the various levels
of the conspiracy the simple conspiracy
is that someone snuck in there and
murdered him right on the cameras off
and then there's a conspiracy that they
just knew he was suicidal and so they
just encouraged whoever they get they
gave him the the means to do it himself
but he he requested to be taken off
suicide watch
through his lawyers yeah his lawyers
should have his best interests at heart
I imagine like yeah he he he's
essentially I guess was a psychopath he
was a person who could manipulate people
very easily so he was able to make the
the prison psychiatrist think that he
wasn't going to kill himself mmm he's
probably being all happy and positive
and looking forward to the trial and
things like that and but he was just
doing it with the idea that he was gonna
kill himself because he's a guy who can
manipulate people so it doesn't seem at
all unreasonable the you know if you
request a psychiatrist to evaluate you
for the suicide watch they have to do it
so this is a kiya Trish comes and
evaluates and for the suicide watch
Epstein's all all happy jolly and
positive he has to take him off it and
then so they put him on to me or
whatever the occasional checks type
thing and he finds twenty minutes and
kills himself
I think it is a likely explanation that
it was um let's say suicide by
opportunity yeah but here did somebody
not deliberately not but does put him on
that list doesn't he need that means to
commit suicide everyone has the means
once that put back in gen-pop they're
jealous he he wasn't in general puppy it
was it was taken out of the cell the
suicide watch cell which has like
special bunks and things he doesn't have
any bars where you can tie anything from
it and I think they've it there's
various levels of suicide watch the most
extreme one is a five-point restraint
where they they tie down your arms and
legs in your head and then it goes down
from there so they should tie down your
arms or legs and there's the manacle
year sometimes they will give you
clothing that you can't use that will
rip and then there's the cells that are
special cells with no bars he was in a
Cell that had a bunk bed and if you got
a cell with a bunk bed that's got a bar
on it you can tie something to it you
can kill yourself mm-hm you just use
your pajama pants or something wrap and
bungee neck and to tie it to the thing
and then just you know lean for net
broke although his his hyoid bone broke
which is a little bone right here it's
kind of like a wishbone he goes around
from one side the other I think it's
like a structural thing for you voice
box and this is a bone that breaks quite
commonly when people are strangled hmm
it's also a bone that breaks quite
commonly when old people commit suicide
it's a bone that becomes more brittle
with age so a person in their 60s or 70s
he was 65 I think if they commit suicide
by by hanging it's very likely that that
bone will break people make a lot of it
because people want to make a lot of it
you hear a lot of people making noise
about this and they say oh this is
something that happens when people are
strangled but if he was strangled
obviously to the point of breaking that
bomb there would be other signs of
strangulation right yeah probably yeah
but there's also being strangled isn't
that different from being hanged if you
go if you do they could probably you
garrote him from behind and make it look
like a hanging but that you this is a
next level up conspiracy that means
there's to be someone else in the
CEL actually doing it if you wanted
Epstein dead and you're a high-level
individual I think it would be smarter
and less risky just to give him the
means and the timeframe to do it himself
because clearly he had already attempted
it yeah I mean that I would probably the
first first step yeah I mean if you
think if you posit that there was a
conspiracy then it's possible that they
said well let's just leave him there for
a while and see if he takes care of
himself and if we if not then we'll jump
in there and do something but we don't
really have any evidence of you the
later stages of it I'm an actual active
thing we just have this evidence of what
could be just incompetence in the prison
system because it's this hugely
overworked federal prison system and I
feel like that is probably the most
likely because once you say it really
makes me think about other stuff and how
true that is like you think something as
big as like a huge company would be so
organized but once you actually get
familiar with it a lot of times you
realize it's really far from something
you like that's slick and like when I
was in the Army I thought everything
would be so organized such a serious
operation and it's like so not so
incompetent yeah and then Speier sees
often give people too much credit too
much guy yeah yeah well there's stuff by
people the corporation's are full of
people and yeah I mean the prison system
is full of people and they fail their
people make mistakes but the Bolivia
thing I mean it's it's like every single
way along I think that's probably just
more evidence the same type of thing
they don't they didn't have the staff to
keep things like that up but it was
Epstein of all people yeah just some
random yeah so that that kind of shows
you that he wasn't given some kind of
special treatment which I think it's of
anything that the Justice Department was
a little bit too Cavalier or maybe they
were a little too much like a it's it's
totally fine if this dude ends up dead
could be okay yeah but yeah we it's just
that's obviously a speculation because
it could have been the other thing so
the lists I what so rank it for me right
when you say suicide are you talking
about
so when you say suicide clarify just
suicide by pure negligence of of the
yeah that's that the people there or
suicide by an opportunity given I would
I would rank just regular suicide as the
first thing mmm-hmm just underneath that
I would rank the some kind of
opportunity given make them not putting
him on permanent suicide watch
deliberately or just not making a big
deal about it
look no giving they say don't give him
any special treatment you know I'll put
that as a second but you've kind of
lower down I'd say you would think that
the Justice Department would be like
this guy cannot kill himself and you
know everyone was already saying oh he's
gonna end up dead like jokingly
everybody was like that guy's gonna die
prison for sure and you would think that
the officers and the Justice Department
would be like no not honor that would be
true if things were run as they should
they're runners do they should when the
when the when the Attorney General says
hey guys this guy can't die you know the
whole Justice Department can be in
disarray but once the Attorney General
specifically calls up your prison and
says this guy stays alive he stays alive
sir because he didn't do that yeah yeah
is that a conspiracy of omission did he
deliberately not do it or did they just
never say certainly at the very worst
it's such extreme negligence that I
almost in almost well they're looking
for scapegoats right now they fired the
director of Prisons and his replacement
is the previous director of Prisons who
retired like seven years ago some some
old lady who hasn't worked in the prison
system for like last seven years that
would be good yeah yeah she was doing a
better job than he was doing yeah
obviously the stuff needs needs fixing
in the prison system but is that the
only factor so you say prison by
negligence or I mean suicide by
negligence yeah just regular regular
suicide and that's just the system
failed him and then number two would be
suicide by opportunity number two would
be like somebody helped the system fail
in yeah they knew that they which would
be conspiratorial yeah yeah that's
pushing and then you can have got
various levels of that you know how much
did they help did
did you know if you get to an actual
conspiracy of someone doing something
positive then they would say like the
guards should not be in his cell at this
time right and then you've got like
they're super conspiracies of him being
killed by someone sneaking into his cell
and then you got the super duper
conspiracies oh he's still alive and he
never died at all and they spirited him
away and just so he did that that one is
something like that these people who
apparently shared in his escapades with
him cared enough like these are this is
a great already sight parrot a double
body I mean these are psychopaths yeah
these are Psychopaths with Psychopaths
they they would not you know lift a
finger to save him
but regardless so now when we look back
at who Epstein was and who he associated
with do you think it's possible for
example that Bill Clinton could fly on
his private plane with him what was it
like 26 times and not know what he was
up to
sure if you look at those actual trips
one of them was a big trip around Africa
which was 11 stops so 26 26 of those
those flights were just this one trip
around around Africa and Europe and
Paris
how many eleven okay you still have 15
yeah I think six of them were for one
trip to Asia hmm that's something you
don't hear yeah which is very compelled
it was like Hong Kong and I think maybe
I went to Russia I'm not sure where it
was it was like something for like the
Clinton Global Foundation or something
and then what does it mean they were
just using his plane yeah yeah I think
he was like you know essentially a
charity type thing that they were doing
so that's fine let's say but okay let's
continue down so let's say there's even
six left seven left on ignored that were
individual flights they're all listed
where he went from and to so we knew we
know what they actually were one of them
was a flight from JFK to Luton which is
in London and then the next day flying
back so yeah is that suspicious maybe
you know is he flying it's plane Bill
Clinton to London so he can he
engage in some nefarious activity maybe
but it seems just like another Michael I
wonder how many people how many flights
how many people I mean flights are we
talking about here you know what I mean
how frequently was this guy flying
around oh if he flew a lot if you look
at the actual logbooks I was looking at
them last night I was trying to figure
out where all these flights were going
to mmm I did a post on Mehta bunk about
it looking through it all and epsilon is
flying around everywhere it was all
flying with that his new assistant
the lady he's lame as well yeah and a
few other people who was recently seen
in LA at in-and-out the first it was
kind of doctored in a very strange way
was it yeah there was all kinds of being
poster in the background wasn't right we
couldn't figure out every buddy a meta
bunk was looking at this this thing and
trying to figure out you know is this
where it is obviously that in and out
how do you feel when you get turned into
the conspiracy theorist you know that
frequently must happen in your line of
work I I don't really get turned into a
conspiracy theorist but I try to figure
stuff out right so I see something
that's weird
and I think how can this possibly be how
can this this this thing be explained
does it take you to span on it depends
on like that this is your full-time day
look like I mean I did spend hours
looking at these photos of Ghislaine
Maxwell it's the in and out it was an
interesting back yeah sure so it was
like a reflection of a car in the in the
advert and the bus stop so I did a
little 3d model so I could check to see
if the angles were right with the other
car yeah you know you you eliminate one
possibility and brings you closer to the
truth yeah it really wasn't very
important you know that's just you know
that poster was just a PR thing on her
her part but she was reading some book
about CIA age yeah it's almost like you
know trying to send a message or
something like because it was it was a
photo shoot that was staged by her
I think a publicist friend or a real
brand or something and you know they
obviously she probably picked which book
yes makes more sense than sitting in
another cycle they're all Psychopaths
okay maybe they pick the book that they
thought which is mess with people the
most and get me talking and maybe the
edited all this stuff I mean I thought
people would talk about it a psycho can
you be at a time when you're a your prop
let's I don't know her involvement with
him but she was certainly a lifetime
partner of his oh yeah
and so to trivialize the whole thing by
kind of sitting out of in and out with
the CIA book is pretty psychotic yeah
who knows what's going on yeah be you
look at look at the flight logs she's
listed and pretty much every flight was
emails so now when you that that's
really interesting what you say about
Bill Clinton yeah that yet they
certainly omit that how they never would
mention never heard a you know 27
flights could actually I mean like three
trips
yeah it's six six trips I think in total
that's incredible that is such a big 20
as well that just him doing his Clinton
Global Initiative Wow status that's
incredible so there you go I mean the
way that information is presented make
solidarity yeah yeah and some people
present you know he flew on the loliter
expressed 26 times yeah and then that
becomes he flew on the loliter expressed
to the private island which I regret and
he never did there's no evidence he ever
went there
oh that leaders there's one of the girls
now woman says that she saw him you know
like 15 years ago there or something
like that so he has actually been
someone has actually said that he was
there but there's no actual real
evidence other than that they went there
certainly not the flights it's it is
interesting how how connected he was he
was also friends with with Donald Trump
a car president it's very interesting
you know yeah he what was print with
with the royal family and people don't
really know how he made his money right
right this is weird
he was a hedge fund manager then when
upon further inspection he hadn't made
much money managing funds is that right
yeah I think he was essentially a money
manager for very rich people what
billionaires would give him money and he
would invest it for them mm-hmm some
people think he might have been running
some kind of Ponzi scheme
you know pyramid thing like Madoff did
well certainly fits his profile as a
psycho oh yeah yeah I mean you can
totally see it's like if Madoff Bernie
Madoff got away with it
mmm that's Jeffrey Epstein mm-hmm and so
we don't really know what's what
happened you'd be interesting how I only
knew Yeah right
well they they know from the documents
that they've got of him but I don't sure
they don't know everything
by the way IRS another entity they're
completely understaffed and yeah the
guy's filing tax returns and well yeah
that'd be something in there yeah
presumably yeah but you know just
because you're filing tax returns it
doesn't mean you yeah and if you're
running a Ponzi scheme are you gonna put
it on your tax returns well I assumed
that IRS when they see a billionaire
if they see a guy flying around with
private jets and hanging out with like
all these people and he's showing that
he made a million bucks they're gonna be
like let me see yeah he's gonna look
like he made that money so that he's
gonna if he was running some kind of
pyramid sketch show a lot of money gonna
show that people are giving him money
he's investing it and the certain
returns that he's got but they're not
gonna look at the actual you know every
single little detail probably used a
bunch of like offshore accounts as well
yeah yeah disguise it
the Epstein's case is a very interesting
one the connections the mysterious got
it all the mysterious murders I mean
it's really a perfect fodder for
numeracy theorists yeah well there you
have it
I think I think we actually learned a
lot here I think that you mentioned the
Clinton body count as well I think a lot
of people kind of take for granted that
that's a true thing the Clintons are
actually murdered lots of people
certainly a right wing talking point
yeah hold the betrayal it's it's a
pretty old conspiracy theory goes way
back to the 90s someone started a
Clinton body count with
20 people also Oh 20 yeah very generous
now it's hundreds because oh really yeah
does each person accounted for are they
where's the number come from these
people who died these are people who had
some connection with the Clintons and
who are now dead so anyone that knew the
Clemson diet yeah out of the
approximately you know 1 million people
who at some point had some connection to
the Clintons so let me ask you this of
the body count is there any of them that
you find even the slightest bit credible
well there's lots of people who will die
and then you can't say exactly why they
died no but their death benefited those
linens yeah the prob'ly are I'm not you
know aware of them but yeah there's
probably going to be on the law of
average I don't know a hundred it would
help but I don't know there's people
like you know old bodyguards or
relatives of all bodyguards one big one
is the set rich that's the one that you
always hear ya know can you explain cuz
I'm not this is the one that I always
hear I mean by huge right-wing
publications and very popular figures
saying they like you said hold it pretty
much to be very yes Seth rich was a DNC
staffer and the theory goes is that he
was the one who leaked all their stuff
from the DNC the DNC emails the internal
emails and they believed that he was
killed because of that because he was
going to reveal it to the media problem
is that was just a completely made-up
story he is it is a DNC suffered but
there's no evidence whatsoever that he
actually had access to these servers and
took this information from them so
they're they're they're connecting dots
that not evidence and you know he was
killed in what was described as a
botched robbery
hmm yeah so he was he was mugged
essentially but and he'd had nothing
being taken and he was dead they that's
something you can see how it could
happen someone tries to rob somebody so
give me your money they don't give him
the money so they issue them and then
you know you see some people down the
street so you run off it's something
that's quite plausible that could happen
mm-hmm just because it's
a Fischer narrative to make you
suspicious doesn't mean it automatically
is suspicious dan can you pull it up Dan
was saying that FoxNews even at one
point oh yeah the most popular news
outlet in the country had made a story
about it dan can you link me now I think
we should watch that I think that would
be useful yeah and I think they were
forced to retract it as well oh they did
I don't under retraction as well Dan
yeah okay well in CNN and recently had a
really great Donald Trump story they
retracted about they had reported it was
this huge news he said he has Donald's
tax returns and his loans had Russian
oligarchs as co-signers that were close
to Putin and everyone was just like holy
[ __ ] that's crazy and then the next
night they retracted yeah
our Donald had threatened them with
legal action to which if it's not true
fair enough right yeah certainly it's
certainly something that he and he knew
that they wouldn't be able to back it up
yeah yeah maybe there's something there
he probably has some connections to
Russian oligarchs of some level but he
knew that this particular thing wasn't
true so he just pounced on it and was
like you know fake news CNN from his
perspective it was a good thing because
it did and again again it's just another
another loss for ya people who who do
subscribe to this theory that the Trump
is somehow a rush a Russian asset yeah
and I don't think there's any real
actionable evidence like that's what
Mulder found was that there wasn't
enough evidence to point any fingers in
that direction and lots of stuff going
on obviously the Russians did a bunch of
stuff hmm but was there any connection
between what they did and the Trump
campaign there's no real strong evidence
that happened there's circumstantial
evidence people had meetings with
Russians does the famous like Trump
Tower meeting where they yes supposedly
we're getting dirt on Hillary Clinton so
things actually happened the nothing
that raises to the level of something
there's some Ross high-level collusion
between Russia and campaign yeah
certainly wouldn't rule it out that I
wouldn't also bring it to trial right
okay you probably lose
you got that bit away from Tim I'm
trying to find the video it's
surprisingly hard I guess maybe it's not
surprising that it's hard to find Fox's
retraction I'm finding a lot of articles
about how they had to retract the story
but do you have the original story sure
hold on one second yeah well a Hannity
in particular was pushing it and every
night for four weeks on it yeah let me
watch that I want to see the original
story
so I want to get into that but then I
really want to get into the Bob Lazar
yeah choice in Bob Lazar area 51 now
when I see this guy talk I tried to
watch this podcast with him I ever watch
the documentary first mm-hm I mean from
a film perspective I it was just I don't
want I don't wanna be I know a lot of
people subscribed to it so I don't want
to belittle them or dismiss their their
their beliefs but the documentary which
is so poorly made was just so strange
bizarre I couldn't get into it and I'm
looking into the bat the Bob Lazar
podcast Lazar Lazar and well a lot of
stuff doesn't really add up yeah and and
and so I think the claims he makes are
really fascinating you want to believe
it like one of his claims for example he
goes he goes they use for propulsion
he claims first of all that they had 12
or 13 alien spacecrafts and he was one
of the engineers working on them at the
time and he claims that they were there
to reverse engineer the technology
correct me if I'm wrong on this day
that's what he says and then he claims
that the propulsion was fueled by an
atomic element 115 which he explained
generates a gravid gravitational wave
now wasn't there it was there not a
molecule 115 discovered since yeah so
that so that an element that's
compelling right to be like oh I was
working on this but down he discovered
sounds compelling understand the history
of chemistry there's been a continuous
process of filling in the periodic table
all of the elements there being an
atomic number which is the number of
number of protons in the nucleus so you
start out with number 1
which is hydrogen which has one and then
helium has two and an oxygen there's
four wrong but so you just get more and
more and they're the ones that with a
low number are very stable mm-hmm
especially when they're in you know
molecular forms but higher up they
become more unstable so they're very
very hard that you don't find them in
nature basically so all the ones that
are high up on the table they had to
synthesize they had to actually create
them by using some kind of radiation
method and as you got further and
further along they get harder and harder
just just synthesized so what when Bob
Lazar suggested element 115 with 115
protons in the nucleus they just hadn't
got to eat yet
yeah but it was one of the ones that was
the next one along I think they were up
to about 111 112 there this they skipped
them occasionally Kuzma the odd ones are
harder or something like that but it's
something that was inevitably going to
be synthesized at some point and when he
was synthesized it was found to be very
very unstable like he would immediately
just go booth like yeah in milliseconds
really like half a second was his
half-life and he just just vanished but
Bob Lazar claims that he took a pound of
it home with him and it's this stuff
that wouldn't exist in a form that you
got a new person you couldn't have it
you mean it's basically saying right
it'd probably tear apart your cells yeah
because it's disintegrating so rapidly
if you had a lot of it would create a
lot of heat and probably radiation yeah
so it's not something you want to have
around you but it's not something you
can have in in solid form yeah so he
hasn't been vindicated no one's come up
with solid 115 we just come up with a
way to synthesize what we knew was
actually there like this elements
they'll of course we don't have a lien
technology and they would be able to
stabilize it yeah there's the thing if
you introduce something like alien
technology is the explanation that's
like saying oh but we have magic so I
want to I want to ask you kind of like a
meta point about him Joe had him on his
podcast to 7.6 million views the
reception to that was
extraordinarily positive mmm do you
think that it's irresponsible for Joe to
have someone like that on his podcast or
do you like how do you view something
like that I don't think it's causing any
great harm mm-hmm
Joe's was a big fan he's a big UFO guy
and you really likes the story and he
believes Bob Lazar it seems so you know
he's just he's just promoting a story
you think what is it true that a gateway
to the rabbit hole it's I don't really
know like if the UFO thing is the
gateway to the rabbit hole people who
get into UFO stuff they tend to just
stay in UFO stuff because it's so fun
like the aliens is really amazing thing
and it supersedes everything else you
don't even get you don't see any
correlation between unhealthy conspiracy
couldn't go conspiratorial thinking and
and people who generally it was probably
some Oh probably some overlap you you go
from one to the other but a lot of the
people I talk to in say 9/11 they'll say
that I investigate UFOs because I'm
trying to discredit the 9/11 truth
movement they view UFO ology as being
this ridiculous thing that no one should
look at and then the people who Reuters
yeah the truth then the UFO people they
all think that the truthers are
completely crazy and that I shouldn't be
putting them in the same boat as
truthless interests normally you get a
gradation where one is more extreme than
the other but here you've got kind of
two can done overlapping areas there's
also conspiracy shaming yeah my
conspiracy his claims are pretty
extraordinary I mean I'd love for it to
be true it's something fantastic like he
says that he lived in it or he worked in
a facility just outside area 51
dad caves basically dug into the side of
a mountain he worked on flying saucers
he worked on the specifically one called
the sports model which was manufactured
out of a metallic substance similar in
appearance and touch to stainless steel
but apparently had some other property
too
not right what they stainless steel
doesn't sound like fantastic
yeah now you don't have to have some
kind of weird the thing about the things
that he's suggesting is it's some way of
bending gravity repenting bending
space-time essentially which is the same
thing as gravity which is a popular you
know and in sci-fi
oh yeah and exactly it's it's not a new
concept certainly no and it would have
been something he would have been aware
of when he wrote these things you know I
think essentially he made it all up do
you think that he has drank his own
kool-aid or do you think he's kind of
just doing a social experiment I think
they probably started out just him
having fun making stuff up but over time
a life out I think he might even have
been telling the same thing so long that
he kind of believes that something
happened right because there's so much
detail yeah it's it's totally the same
story over and over again it's not
really that much there he's got a
picture in his head or what he thinks
these these these sources look like
you'll hear him talking about the same
things over and over again like he had a
hatch here it had a honeycomb it was you
know had a half dome and you know did
this it's just telling you the same
story so he has a story down pat and
he's repeating it but it doesn't it
doesn't add up and there's other things
as well like he claimed he went to I
think he was Harvard or Stanford this
that's my favorite thing
he claims he went to both MIT and
Caltech okay however both schools have
no record of him which of course he
claims that the government erased his
academic record to discredit and that
should be aggressively read you can't
isn't that great attend to schools for
many years and have know everything
you've done but they'll let you go yeah
why didn't they go back and get there
well why not just kill him exactly if
the government yeah you know just just
throw him off the side of the flatter
yeah it makes no sense and I think like
there's a theory kind of behind why what
he does
which is that he did actually have some
classified information about secret
stuff that was going on there not aliens
just he knew some stuff about that's
something else that was happening there
so they were testing like some weapon
proton beam or something and when he
when he gave it up this crazy story out
to people they the powers that be
thought it was better for him to keep
giving out this crazy story rather than
giving the truth of what's actually
going on there hmm so they figured like
you know as long as he's just saying
this stuff that's fine we don't had to
do anything so that's a deeper
conspiracy that suggests that he's
colluded with the government yeah no
it's not really conspiracy it's just
they're leaving him alone because yeah
because it's they don't want to have to
take more drastic action okay yeah I
love the I love the the MIT Caltech
story yeah that seems so obvious to be
able to check that stuff just don't even
live out your education just say I'm
self-taught yeah which essentially he
was you know he was is a smart guy he's
a smart guy you got Peters physics he
does chemistry he runs you know a store
where you can buy all kinds of weird
chemicals there's other way stuff in his
past like he once installed plus circuit
TV system in a brothel and he got got
arrested for some kind of thing related
to this there's brothel and divider
right yeah I read about that he was uh
he's associated with the broth oh yeah
people put that mistakes in the past but
he prefers people to look at this
imaginary tenure at MIT and Caltech he
also claims that he read briefing
documents describing the historical
involvement with earth for the past ten
thousand years by extraterrestrial
beings called grey aliens these aliens
are from a planet orbiting the twin
binary star system Zeta Reticuli more
like a Zeta ridiculous have you heard
that before yes I have
that's probably a ridiculous ridiculous
reticle with its ret particular yeah yes
that's I think that actually comes from
an earlier UFO stories mm I think thank
you I'm not entirely sure where I think
he was Barney and Betty hill with these
famous UFO abductees and they claim that
the aliens had talked to them and they
said they came from Zeta reticulan
and so he would have heard this so he's
picking up this same thing there is
something that would have been going
around in UFO circles yeah this is this
is the place where the gray aliens come
from so everyone get your stories
straight when you need to talk to people
right yeah so what do you think goes on
in area 51 then if anything I think they
test advanced weapons and stuff like in
Des Plaines they a lot of the stuff
isn't just simply like building planes
is building the systems and the weapons
that go on the planes stole like why why
would you need you know thousands of
miles of empty acreage of desert in case
you plane crushes plane crash weapon
test yeah there's a whole bunch of
different sites out there there's the
sites about testing munitions and things
and ranges where they shoot things if
you're gonna do stuff like you know
shoot a rocket up you wouldn't
first of all you you want to have you
wouldn't have a buffer zone you know
people can't stand on the edge outside
the fence and a stepladder and take a
photo of things right so you got to have
miles and miles around you that just
keep you from everywhere else right and
you want to have lots of options for
doing various things like different
terrain and whatnot so this is something
that was recently did this morning by
the Air Force like they had recently
unveiled that they were spending twenty
two million dollars in investigating
UFOs because it was happening quite
frequently that members of the Air Force
we're seeing unidentified objects moving
and really inexplicable ways for example
this video
the New York Times speaking with five
Navy pilots who've all said they've
encountered UFOs during training
missions up and down the East Coast
the pilots even noting that the objects
were accelerating to hypersonic speed
making sudden stops and instantaneous
turns something beyond the physical
limits of a human crew we submit a
safety report saying that there was a
object in our working space we don't
know what to do this on the eve of a new
History Channel series called
unidentified insiders turn into an ad
yeah that video there is called the
gimbal video and that video and the
other two videos there you've seen their
stuff that I've done a lot of work on
analyze those so tell me what do you
think about it on that video there is
almost certainly an infrared layer when
a plane gets very far away the glare
from the engine can get so big that it's
actually bigger than the plane itself in
terms of just what it looks like on
camera you can imagine like you know a
very bright light on camera just you can
let out and it looks bigger than the
actual object itself like someone's
holding a flashlight at night mm-hmm
flashlights pretty small but you see
this bright light around it right that's
viewing something in infrared and it's
black hot so it's actually inverted it
would normally be like a Hawaii white
thing there and what's happening is the
internal optics of the camera is what's
making it rotate it's kind of
complicated to explain I could like a
bunch of it yes it's firing I think
would be hard to dissuade anyone with
that because it's so complex but also
when I'm thinking is like obviously the
Air Force would understand that why
would they release it and and fuel they
didn't exactly release it the Air Force
didn't release it it was one guy Louis
Elizondo who now works for the to the
Stars Academy which is Tom DeLonge
organization why'd you left in because I
know about Tom DeLonge whole thing and
he's he's crazy yeah yeah unda long is
like believes really passionately that
there is alien visitors out there and
that by wait he's a senator or something
right Tom DeLonge no
it was a former frontman for blink-182
okay as credible as it gets
because I know there was a I had been
reading that there was a member of
Congress that was responsible for this
twenty two million dollar Harry Reid
yeah Harry Reid the senator from Nevada
Reid yeah it is you know the leader of
whatever he was wasn't it wasn't it
speculated be somewhat of a corrupt
thing because he was yeah the the money
went to essentially rob Bigelow Bigelow
airspace Bigelow has got contract with
NASA to make inflatable habitats for the
space station so it's a real legit
person but he also has a very strong
interest in UFOs and things and he can I
share this interest with with Harry Reid
who's his friend hmm
and so Harry Reid set this thing up and
Bigelow became the recipient of a lot of
this stuff and a lot some of it
yeah like reporting UFOs and start
setting up a database and also just
giving back twenty two million dollars
to your friend yeah well your friends
company is something that I would
encourage people to look into the I'm
not gonna like you know point any
fingers without knowing his health he
went on I think yeah they it was a
proper contract it was awarded to
Bigelow and it's just a standard type of
government pork essentially here
somebody got something for their friend
happens all the time like you get a
bridge built in your hometown or
whatever it doesn't necessarily mean
it's super corrupt it's just just
corruption light the normal type of
corruption that we have in America we
have a good tolerance yeah the pork
system in America when I see add things
on it was twenty two million over five
years it ran for those five years they
never really found anything of any
interest and so the program was shut
down but this one guy Lewis Elizondo
he's saw him briefly there he continued
to be really interested in the topic and
he claims he was still working on it and
he claims the the operation was still
going on but he eventually left and as
he was leaving he made a request that
three videos that he knew of these three
famous videos gimbal and two of those be
declassified interest
because he wanted to use them for Tom
DeLong's organization so he would be the
back and forth
he got them Declassified the Navy didn't
release them as stuff they just looked
at them and said yeah that's nothing you
can have that and gave it to him and
then they presented as being this
amazing UFO videos when they all have
quite reasonable explanations there's
another one called go-fast which looks
like a UFO scheming really really fast
over the surface of the ocean the good
thing about that video is you have all
the all the numbers on the screen so you
can figure out the angles at the camera
and you can do a bit of trigonometry and
you can figure out exactly where this
object is in space and it turns out it's
not over the water and it's not actually
moving really really fast it's probably
something like a balloon or a bird
there's actually hovering around 10,000
feet and because the plane is flying
past it the parallax makes it look like
it's moving really really fast as the
camera is constantly pointing at it and
turning around so these things have
explanations but that's not what not on
the long one not that fun of an
explanation yeah what did you just send
me oh I believe it's the video he's
referring to yeah yeah let's [ __ ] let's
show it for reference that's extremely
compelling yeah it looks like it's
something that's look at that moving
really really fast you got to remember
the jet itself
this isn't shot from a helicopter this
is shot from a jet that's moving Mac
point six you it looked like the planes
- doing a hundred fifty-four knots like
calibrated sphere which is about 300
dots over 300 miles an hour
350 so it's focused on this thing which
is floating around 10,000 feet up in the
air and there's the ocean way beyond it
so it looks like that's a problem
yeah for someone who's completely
unequipped to understand what they're
looking at yeah like myself you know
just I just I would just think the
camera is not even moving you do from
the numbers like earlier on there was
you could see that it was I think it was
tilted down to a certain angle and then
when there was a range we tells you how
far away it is so it's tilted down at
this angle is this far away very very
simple triggered on
just like here the sine of the angle
multiplied by this gives you how far
away it actually is or how high it is so
you can you know work it out at high
school high school student could have
worked out what it was but the to the
Stars Academy Tom DeLonge they didn't
work out they didn't do the math yeah
and they kept this carry on to this day
yeah claiming that it's at sea level
when you can just do the math and it's
not a sea level that's incredible it
really looks like the the camera is
stationary yeah yeah and I think when
you realize that yeah that 2 5 4 in the
corner is the speed calibrated airspeed
in knots which is actually less than the
actual earth speed but you realized that
and you being viewed from 25,000 feet
its 3.4 nautical miles away and angled
down at 22 degrees so you can just work
out from that where it is and he works
out at the ground 13,000 feet which is
about halfway to the to the ocean
certainly these pilots must see stuff
like this all the time if it's just like
a bird or other video and because I
remember we talked about it when it came
out like we read the article and it said
that they reported that they would see
it multiple times a day that they're
seeing other things their thing is about
all these videos is that we don't really
we have all these reports from pilots
and they say they say things like lights
in the distance or occasionally things
zipping by them and then we have these
videos but we don't have the two
together we don't have a pilot saying I
took a video of this thing and it was
doing this stuff
so you've got like the reflecting yeah
you've got this was one pilot saying
there was a tic-tac that was like
zipping around like this and then they
also show a video of something that's
not doing anything not it's a different
video that you just see this little
white dot in the distance and it's not
moving at all and they say well you know
we got the evidence but there's no
connection between this guy and this
video so we need to get the person who
took the video to say what's actually
going on and we don't have that and we
have explanations for the very
interesting stuff I think that's great
is there any UFO footage that through
the
there's so much by now that's been
captured and suppose it evidence if you
ever seen anything that you found
inexplicable or no tiling and a night
well there's two different things the
inexplicable and compelling yeah you
don't generally see those two things
together right you see inexplicable
things all the time you see a little
white dot up in the up in the sky and
you can't explain what it is exactly you
can come up with some hypotheses as to
one it might be it might be a plane or
it might be a blimp or it might be a
balloon or it might be a bird or might
be a cloud it might be a little bit of
lint that's very close to you or some
kind of seed or something that's very
close to you you could be having a
temporary or like brain storm or
something and your visual systems messed
up
there's all kinds of things that things
might be mm-hmm
but the often you can't figure out what
it is so the fact that we have UFO
videos that are not identified is is
going to be a given
UFOs exists at the boundary between
identifiable and not you know
identifiable so they're just a little
bit beyond if we could zoom in on the
things you can identify them hmm so as
camera technology has improved recently
UFOs tend to get further and further
away now we used to get photos of UFOs
which were just like hovering over
people's houses now we get ones that are
like hovering over and it by mountain
because we've got these super zoom
cameras that can zoom we're not all the
way we're we're all carrying around like
high-definition 4k cameras enough so the
boundary at which UFOs exist that
somehow shifted further and further away
as camera technology has improved
because we're able to now to identify
all these things that are close if I'd
supposed to take something where photo
with my iPhone is such high resolution
you can you can tell what things are was
when people were taking pictures with
the Kodak Instamatic it wishes this
blurry little blob yeah
do you think there's a problem like with
the theory of aliens visiting the earth
to begin with yeah is that a plausible
theory at all it it's a possible theory
I wouldn't call it a plausible theory
you gotta look at like you know the
evidence for the existence of aliens to
start off with there's complete radio
silence
throughout the the entire nearby galaxy
we don't have any signals coming in from
people that we can even point as being
slightly alien like I'm actually having
a guest on my podcast next week or the
sets Shostak it was the head of SETI
mm-hmm the search restoration really
intelligence and he'll tell you they
haven't really had any good candidates
signals the occasion to get excited
about something and then they figure out
it was just the microwave down the hall
but but yeah that there hasn't been any
indication that there are any aliens who
use radios to communicate nearby in or
and you think that these stars the
light-years away so that radios way to
take quite a while to get here and so
we've got kind of like snapshots of
history at various distances away and
none of them have civilizations and we
didn't know like how long will the
civilization last for mm-hmm if a
civilization was actually very very good
and you know at surviving they would
actually populate the galaxy relatively
quickly because they other send ships to
nearby stars and populate all those
things so you would expect to see a lot
of it a lot the bacteria yeah yeah like
stars everywhere being turned into Dyson
spheres which are where they need all
the energy to right to power things
quite depressing yeah we don't see we
don't see anything it feels like we're
in this dead galaxy a lot how far away
can we tell can we see I guess visible
light right yeah yeah we can see the
stars so we could see if there was some
kind of large structure around the star
there was recently an interesting thing
where they found this star that had this
kind of it was variable in a way that
made them think it was something like a
Dyson Sphere going around the star with
holes in it so the star would shine out
now on that I think that turned out to
be you know something something else for
that one yeah baby so yeah it's like
that's that's the one that's the one
thing that's going and he was probably
like you know a hundred million light
years away right do you ever run out of
conspiracies like there's always
something new coming along and he said
often like the the events themselves
will create conspiracies like yeah we
got
yep scene but even things like the
Hurricanes there's always gonna be
people making theories that the
hurricane was steers the political
reasons that came was steered yeah that
would be an incredible power to yield
yeah yeah I would think it would
probably use it for good if they could
do well yeah we can actually get you
know cyclones in New Mexico which in
theory can't do I do occasionally have
to get up to LA like once every hundred
years or so you get like a super storm
here which is yeah essentially a
hurricane so how is it how is it that
they explained that the government can
control the trajectory of a hurricane
yeah there's a variety of things but the
most popular thing is this thing called
HAARP H AARP yeah which is this big
radio transmitter in Alaska which
doesn't do anything of the sort
it's it's kind of a space radio thing in
that it will heat up a layer of the
atmosphere called the ionosphere which
is about 200 miles up and it can just
heat this up pretty much directly over
this one station in Alaska and it does
pretty much nothing it's kind of like
you know you're tossing some dye into a
river or something he makes it but for
what purpose does it heat it up the
creates that is studying at it's there's
there's no rain coming from ionosphere I
all the weather that happens in in the
planet happens in the bottom like 10
miles or so I've got a picture of this
facility you're talking above above 10
miles there isn't really any weather and
way up in the ionosphere is essentially
in space there's really nothing there is
just just a few light loose electrons
and things has been around so they're
able to heat it up from here though yeah
it's kind of like a you know like a
microwave and it's it's tuned in a way
when it resonates with the angle of the
magnetic field of the earth so they do
better this is able to control a
hurricane in Florida yes that they think
they're also other ones as well like
this measured on a ship as well
yes and why are we trying to - why we're
trying to do a submerge Florida but why
they're doing this is they're trying to
study radio communications basically
even you can bounce things off the
ionosphere to get around the curve of
the earth
earth is actually curved and so by
studying the ionosphere you can figure
out how to actually do that Bess mmm so
they artificially like to bitly it
wobble up and down and heat it up and
it's pretty interesting yeah yeah it's
by itself it's interesting enough uh
top-secret research around it as well
they they were using it for
communications with submarines the I
don't think it really works but they use
submarines underwater you can
communicate them with very very very
long wave radio waves like wavelengths
of hundreds of feet miles even can
penetrate through the water and they do
it often by having these very very long
antennas on the ground like the tens of
miles long but they thought they could
also do it by wobbling their hair on the
sphere to a certain degree to create
some kind of radio wave off there which
would then be able to communicate with
it's a bunch of like secret research and
speculative stuff it's mostly hard
science though it's people just studying
the ionosphere like astronomers study
stars just how it works right well we're
coming up on two hours so I'm gonna skip
to the end I've got I got some other
stuff but these are these are what I
refer to as like fringe conspiracies
these are these are really deep level
stuff and I think stuff that you could
even say have a real and harmful effect
on society so I'm gonna give you some
off the top of my head if you have an
opinion or a comment about them I'm also
curious what your opinion is like the
most nefarious the most harmful
conspiracy theory generally speaking I
well the one that causes the most harm
to people is the theory that vaccines
cause autism right and that's people and
vaccines in general are harmful so
people don't take vaccines and
gaile everybody it's people people
people died right I mean I'm I'm reading
that the lack of people vaccinating
theirs now jeopardizing people that
cannot vaccinate their yes that exists
if you cut only exists because so many
people are vaccinated like people with
immune problems community problems who
can't get vaccines they're safe because
everyone's vaccinated now that less
people are getting vaccinated other
people's children are starting to to get
these rare and otherwise thought to be a
you know extinguished
yeah these eases yeah some people are
they can't be vaccinated because they
actually have immune system problems
that said the vaccines don't work with
them what the vaccines would kill them
mmm and so they do rely on this thing
called herd immunity where if like
ninety five percent of people are
vaccinated around them the chances of
them coming into contact with someone
with the disease is very very low so
they're pretty safe yeah but if you take
away that hood immunity and you start
getting down to like sixty percent then
you're gonna bump into people who are
ill and then what happened everyone is
like have you ever been able to flip an
anti-vaxxer I didn't really talk to
anti-vaxxers not because I don't want to
it's just I tend to deal with topics
that are more you know obscure like
chemtrails 9/11 forest fires things like
that like the more unusual things
there's lots of very good people working
on anti vaccine yeah so I'm gonna leave
it to them so I've got anti vex I got
queuing on q and on he went on is that
is is the theory that there's someone
deep inside the government yeah that is
leaking information that basically
everyone in power is a deep conspiracy a
pedophilia ring yeah yeah they think
that the the government is run by
corrupt elites that sacrifices children
partly so it can harvest their adrenal
glands oh because it's this thing
adrenochrome which makes them like
Forever Young oh wow thing the adrenal
glands secrete so they torture children
which makes more adrenochrome and then
take out the adrenochrome and then
throw away the children and then they
inject themselves and they live forever
well you know I imagine actually
believing that I mean how horrific of a
thing to think is going on around here
and they think you know this Q person
apparently is this secret person within
the government a lot of people think
it's actually Donald Trump right doing
this Q and on stuff but he's not these
day he just joined the coach said though
the cueing on people all they're all big
fans of Donald Trump they all think he
is basically the savior right either he
is running this qa9 thing as this secret
operation or the military is doing a
kind of a coup by instant they they got
him elected and then they using all this
this flimsy military the good yeah it's
military of the good guys I said Trump
is the puppet but how can Donald Trump
be deep state like I said what's the
explanation for that because he's only
been president now for what three years
almost he's not deep straight I think
he's like somebody a super talented guy
that they the military recruited as that
person they saw him on the apprentice
and they saw how good he was on the
apprentice and they figured he'd be a
really good guy to be cueing on and give
clues to people on eight channels what
is it that there's always got to be a
thread right some some some touch of
reality to get people mm-hmm what is it
and that one morning q and on them
that's right a reality I think they just
don't want to think that Donald Trump is
who he actually appears to be right
there were such big fans of me at Donald
Trump and they were kind of disappointed
when he just turned out to be this guy
who tweets a lot of nonsense all the
time and so they wanted there to be this
fantasy nothing there's yeah there's
obviously there's people in government
doing things that aren't you know on the
surface visible how serious are these
people a lot of these especially kind of
Donald Trump right-wing because there
seems to not really believe it yeah it's
hard to tell some some people seem very
very serious yeah yeah you think that
they don't because it's so ridiculous
but then you think that about flutter of
people and you find people do actually
do the earth is flat so people do
actually believe this cue and answer and
a lot of them
I think the cueing on people they don't
really understand the extent of the
ridiculousness over there
hmm they just think that there's there's
something going on that the Muller
investigation was a cover for a
different investigation which maybe
makes a bit of sense but now the mother
investigation is over and nothing really
happened 8chan has actually been shut
down now mmm so Q can't can't keep his
messages out anymore so I think Q and on
is essentially over and in the form it
was in I say it will no doubt he'll find
it no the echoes of it I mean that's
route to a future but it's something
that's ended pizza gate is another one
that was a similar favorite of the right
now my take on pizza gate was was this I
mean I have talked about the Catholic
Church prolific child abuse and I think
to myself these are conservative people
I mean who are accusing democratic way
is about them Democratic members of
government here molesting and raping
children in the basement of this pizza
store yet on the other hand I'm thinking
well the Catholic Church is one of the
most prolific enablers of child abuse
and yet they don't seem to level much
criticism there I find that to be a
little bit uneven yeah yeah well I guess
like the everyone's fully aware of the
Catholic Church stuff now and it's gonna
be out in the open so you criticize the
Pope for you know he's he's stood up
against the things so I don't know if
that's a good analogy because they're
they're saying there's this secret thing
going on where these people are secretly
doing this and it's actively going on
right now in in the basement of kamek
kamek ping pong I think our comic pizza
in DC we doesn't actually have a
basement right as the guy found out when
he tried weapon yeah to rescue all the
Kurds and there's no peace he shot into
a room when he ended up just using a
computer or something and it was in
there in there he could have killed
someone
of course this is where thirst can be
harmful people take them so seriously
but they get a gun and go someone
absolutely and why shouldn't they if
they truly believe that right yeah
that's the part he was trying to rescue
children he was trying to do better in
time
yeah there's a wonderful good guy but he
got it completely wrong yeah and they
shouldn't do tonight yeah
Sandy Hook one of the most probably
nefarious conspiracy theories of all
tons of children were murdered by a
psycho yet there was a large populace of
people that thought it was all a fake
to enable gun gun laws is that right
yeah which apparently didn't work now
anyway nobody wanted to do it anyway
whenever something like this happens
people buy more guns yeah you could say
like the NRA is behind it because what
happens is the gun legislation does not
change and people buy a lot more guns
and so there's more guns out there and
makes it harder for them to take away
all the guns yeah these these mixed
answer theories don't ever make sense
you see it every time there's a shooting
yeah see every time there's no actual
meaningful change done to the
legislation so I don't really get that
theory yeah and I see people like Shane
Dawson like talked about that and yeah
it was it was he was repeating some of
the stuff that people put around but he
brought up some stuff on our podcast
like the dad laughing yeah and I just
really don't it's ridiculous that guys
called Robbie Parker the guy he's
referring to and remember these are
people who let's just give them the
benefit of the doubt have had their
children perfectly murdered yeah a few
days ago he was it was his daughter's
funeral and he was gonna speak but
before he got to the microphone he was
talking to some really and he laughed so
you see him laughing and then he comes
to the microphone in his all serious but
to me that seems like a perfectly
understandable thing you go to a funeral
and we've all been to funerals like
people people do to chat and they laugh
yeah you just spend you get taken out of
your head for a moment and things feel
like they're normal and so you just talk
and you make a joke or whatever and
you're laugh yeah and then you know
you've got to go and stand in front of a
microphone and talk about your dead
daughter certainly that that is an
extraordinary claim support is simply by
dude laughing yeah I mean it's
ridiculous like you really I feel like
in that case you have to think maybe of
the consequence of making claims like
that
because I've heard that some of the
Sandy Hook parents have been harassed so
so um relentlessly that they've had to
move around they had to change their
identity I mean come on yeah the people
have been they go up to them and accuse
them of being actors you imagine and
shout about their dead children like
show me the Shelby the death certificate
no shout at them for the dead children
then imagine you're in grieving for your
dead child and you don't even get you
don't even get to have that yeah this is
pretty bad and that's one of the hardest
conspiracies for me to deal with I
originally didn't even want to talk
about it because it was just these
complete [ __ ] making it is
ridiculous really hurtful conspiracies
about people something that made me
write more about it was the Boston
Marathon bombing because my
father-in-law was actually in the Boston
Marathon at the time and he was just
behind where the bomb went off it was
actually fairly close well to the to the
finish line at the time so he could have
actually been involved in it so I kind
of felt like a bit of a personal
connection with that and then people
started saying the entire thing was fake
and that there was fake blood and they
use amputees and they whipped the legs
off and yes miss bit burn over over them
it was just such a ridiculous thing and
I know what was the I don't know what
could have been killed
sure you had yeah well what what is the
explanation for again it wire wire why
is someone faking the attack ah what end
I don't know what the Boston Marathon
bombing thing at especially because
there were two Muslim guys who did it so
it's trying to stoke up anti-muslim
sentiment justify Wars and things like
that from maps you can always come up
with some reason yeah there's some kind
of justification under your conspiracy
theory right chemtrails is one you know
I started looking at the chemtrails
recently because in preparation for this
mm-hmm and I didn't realize that it was
actually just referring to the
condensation trail behind clients yeah
gracious and I was just flabbergasted
you know and I'm trying to I was trying
to put myself into their shoes I think
in LA where I've lived most of my life
the condensation
dissipates quicker possibly because that
may be where other where people live it
stays for longer and I've seen images of
skies where there's just tons so I can
see them made it being more alarmed by
every time they look in the sky it's
just airplane lines
yeah the patterns do vary a lot by
location like here in LA we're very
close to LAX obviously and Burbank so
the most of the air traffic we see is
actually fairly low it's like planes
landing mmm you don't get that much over
flights whereas if you look at somewhere
like in the middle of the country you're
in a big route between LA and New York
in and then Florida and Seattle and as
this crossroads in the in the middle of
the country and there's these crossroads
everywhere it's not just in the middle
of the country yeah well you get all
these high flying planes people say like
you know I don't leave anywhere near an
airport and you know see all these
contrails that's what you see most of
the contrails not near an airport so
people just don't understand like what
they're seeing yeah and I think because
when I see people talking about it they
say like I see this in that in the sky
more and more and it freaks me out I
think I'm not but I think I've never
seen a sky like they have to not that
I'm not that not that it's happening but
trying to put all right sure you you
yeah you personally wouldn't have liked
living here you don't see that you
occasionally like some of the biggest
contrails you get in LA are actually
flights from Hawaii made flying in and
over the country of life flying over
Haddie's and but they a lot of them are
just like fairly small planes I mean
like here for example if this is what
your sky looked like all the time that's
certainly something I would think a lot
more about yeah and I do here in in LA I
mean I don't think that's Kim chilling
that's just a cloud but yeah yeah
there's a lot going on here I love those
by the way
they're very cool they're very I mean
the only ones I really fear from like
the air force really crazy ones yeah the
ones that go round in circles you
actually see planes leaving circular
contrails I've seen them here like over
Catalina Island Raytheon does test
flights over there sometimes and they
fly around in these big oval shapes the
occasion and you'll see what looks like
these worried words suspicious contrails
like over over the ocean and people will
put photos of them up but you know that
we know what the plane is you can
actually look up the plane a lot of
times you can
use your phone there's this apps you can
get for your phone like flightradar24
you can just install that and then you
just look it at the sky and it overlays
what the planes are actually are on your
phone so you can figure out very easily
that it's just a regular passenger plane
right from A to B yeah and that one
really shocked the hell out of me
because I feel like it's pretty easily
explainable that the fuel leaves off
water you're high up in the atmosphere
it's probably freezing right like what
stuff yeah yeah it's there above 30,000
feet so the temperature is is like minus
40 degrees yeah and the exhaust
basically it it freezes is a bit more
complicated actually condenses out into
tiny water droplets and then the water
droplets freeze mm-hm
but that's what's happening it's just
creating a cloud no and B it is exactly
the same basically as a cloud you're
referring to don't maybe yeah that's my
site control science comm that's my
other side but also the the premise that
that could you even from that high up
like drop a meaningful amount of
chemicals actually there's a it's kind
of a proof of chemtrails not existing
which is a little complicated but you
basically figure out how much a cloud
weighs and clouds have a certain mass
per per unit volume so like so a cubic
meter of a cloud weighs so much like say
like you know one gram or something of
water and you figure out how big is this
contrail if you've got a controller goes
from Horizon to Horizon that's like 100
miles long mm-hmm and it's it's gonna be
like a mile wide and like a fifth of a
mile deep and so you multiply all those
things together and it gives you the
volume then you multiply that by the the
mass of a cloud per unit volume it tells
you the mass of material that would be
required to make that contrail and it
ends up being way way way more than the
mass of a fully loaded plane there's no
way you could actually make them that
type of visible cloud when spraying
stuff out of the back yeah the only way
you can make it is by essentially
triggering cloud formation
which then grows mmm so interested the
air where is what they call ice
supersaturated mmm which means like
clouds generally don't form but if a
cloud is created it's gonna stay there
because there's it's about this ice
super saturation level where the ice
persists so when you trigger the
formation of a contrail it's it will
actually grow and more ice so it gets
layered onto these ice crystals and
thicker and thicker and eventually it
becomes this thing that's over a
thousand times more water in it well
then what came out of the ply
interesting oh cool
so you would need a very big plan yeah
it's basically impossible yeah you
couldn't you couldn't do it at all
because the plane wouldn't be able to
fly and and why would you don't need it
because it makes it anyway she's making
well if you had brain control chemicals
you would probably just put it in the
water supply
well the theory is they're using it to
change the the climate that's that's a
popular theory the whole yeah brain
control thing is kind of mine is
arranged okay so why are they so why are
we changing the climate because it's too
hot it's too hot well that seems like a
good thing what's the big secret
yeah I'm not sure it's like they because
they're doing it secretly apparently
this covert geoengineering
some people think that they're actually
heating up the planet it's a fake global
warming okay some people think that
they're trying to cool down the planet
to fix global warming maybe they're
doing both and that's why we're not
saying contrails do actually during the
day they will cool down the planet yeah
night they warm it up because they act
as an insulating blanket so only the
effect of that on average on average no
it's actually not it's actually
significant and it's one of the things
that they the IPCC the international
planet planet Panel on Climate Change
they're actually concerned about this
it's a little chunk of the factors that
are raising the temperature Wow
yeah so that's something that they're
looking into trying to have more
contrails during the day and less
contrail night as a way of actually
helping that's
fascinating yeah there's the there's one
other one that I'm seeing actually was
suggested to us that the government has
a cure for cancer and AIDS etc it
already exists but it isn't made public
because they're they want people to die
or just too much money to be made in
curing chronic diseases yeah well
obviously there's can't be any evidence
no there's there actually there's those
patents patented cures for cancer if you
go to Google and search for patents you
will find things and there's a famous
woman there's a number that they give
and they look at a pattern something
something something other and it's got
this this cure for cancer or is actually
its cure for AIDS but it's kind of this
magic thing where little magic beams zap
your cancer molecules and I did a I did
a whole piece on it on on Medibank but
people think that they have these cures
for cancer there's really no evidence
whatsoever this cures exists patents
don't mean something works a pattern
means so many had an idea yeah and and
they there is the ideas if it worked
it would be great but there's no actual
evidence that this this thing work and
if you read the patterns it's just
completely ridiculous and if you know
anything about cancer you know that
there are all different diseases that
will require a different yeah and yeah
the idea that people would suppress a
cure for cancer just to make it better
that's everybody I mean cancer is
horrible horrible but how many people
are involved in researching and finding
a cure for cancer and then collectively
deciding to hide it and it's not just in
people I have this perspective I think
of America but really good thing at the
entire world you know scientists around
the entire world searching for cures for
cancer and then or all they're not all
conspiring to hide it they're actually
looking for the Cure and if it was there
that they would they would tell people
about it and win the Nobel Peace Prize
it would be the best thing ever if they
manicure for cows oh I know yeah that's
I think that's important to think when
you when you think of these
conspiratorial individuals that they
really living in a dark paranoid off
world yeah that's uh yeah and that's
probably why I try to help them bring
people out of that and they can see the
lights to a degree they can improve
their lives so I have one well one final
question then before we go is you know
many many people report on the existence
of ghosts and supernatural beings one
I'm not a believer personally but one
segment we do on this podcast is we'll
ask our guests you have any guff stores
or supernormal experiences and you'll
find that a lot of people big big
percentage of people do have a story a
story or incident and they are strong
believers in ghosts or UFOs or something
and these are these are people that are
trustworthy people who that we know and
they give they give earnest anecdotes of
encountering something supernatural like
that so how do we explain away this
collective and earnest anecdotes of
people that we trust well these are
people who had an experience that they
can't explain and so for them it's not
too much of a reach for them to say like
you know I had this experience like I
talked to God or whatever or I saw a
ghost and this happens to me and to them
it's very very real my I've had
experiences which convinced me at the
time that I I had supernatural powers I
when I was younger I I guess two numbers
in a school raffle one after the other
and for years afterwards I was convinced
that I had did that but I actually like
gave these numbers out so I think it's
very easy for someone to have an
experience not be able to understand
exactly what happened and then just
accept that there's you know some other
explanation some kind of you know
possibly supernatural explanation and
then they just go with that and then it
just becomes part of who they are
oh yeah tell you tell you tell you
really all this ghost I don't know what
it was but I saw this thing I I have had
experiences where I've had
hallucinations at night my wife and I
both have the same hallucination of
spider
coming down from the ceiling mmm these
giant spiders coming down and like
landing on the bed next to you and
scurrying around and I could totally see
if someone didn't understand that was
just this thing called that thing is a
hypnagogic illusion it's is this thing
that just happens when you're falling
asleep sometimes you see pranks sure if
you didn't understand that and you saw
something that particularly meaningful
to you it's very very easy to think that
that was some kind of mystical thing and
you guys think a lot of people are
religious as well a lot of people
believe in God which is essentially a
supernatural belief so it's a very very
short step from believing in like God to
believing in say angels or spirits
definitely what the ghosts in the end
the religion yeah because you believe
that there is some kind of afterlife it
actually is probably the closest thing
they'll find to verifiable evidence to
support their beliefs yeah so it could
be something that they view is a good
thing because his evidence that the
faith is correct I was kind of surprised
when my dad passed away how old a lot of
people in his family were saying like
you know four he's still here he can
hear what you're saying and like in the
first year he's still gonna be here and
only then they go and they all really
believe that that he's he's listening
over them mm-hmm is that like I'm trying
to get wrap my head around this is
really is this like a paranoid thing
like don't say anything he'll hear you
they say it is like a wholesome yeah
yeah when you're missing him or during
and like after he passed away when
people talk about him you know they're
like you still with us mm-hmm yeah very
religious people yeah my comforts people
yeah nice to think that cuz you know
when someone dies it's very hard that's
just it yeah finally what can we do as
individuals as people to protect
ourselves from conspiratorial thinking
you need to have an open mind and I
think a lot of people who believe in
conspiracy theories think that they have
a right
because they're very open to these also
do you tell the difference if we're not
open mind and a conspiratorial open mind
yeah a few Arkham as if you were a
conspiratorial open mind that means
you're basically rejecting everything on
the other side and you're only listening
to one side you've really got to watch
out for if you're just getting your
information from one source sure maybe
you don't trust other sources maybe you
don't trust the mainstream media but
you've got to at least look at them so
you know what the other side of the
story is don't just look at you know
Alex Jones or whatever it is that you're
looking at look at you know Snopes even
if you think Snopes is government
disinformation read what it says check
it for yourself look at the Wikipedia
articles all the wicked PD articles
they've got references you can go for
this references you can check them for
yourself if you're doing a search for
something don't just search for things
that confirm it search for things that
try to debunk it on things that try to
explain it and give those ago look at
them don't you don't have to believe
them from the start but you can at least
look at them be aware of all sides of
the argument so you can make an informed
decision rather than just listening to
one side of the argument hmm there you
have it that's fair enough
mm-hmm well that was a great
conversation I thank you so much for
coming here thank you I really enjoyed
that me too yeah once again guys check
out Mick's book escaping the rabbit hole
on Amazon and of course his podcast
tales from the rabbit hole
we've got websites that we've just found
on Google Image Search mr. bunk medibang
com yeah I'm drilling on trails which is
dedicated to chemtrails yep and controls
and contrails yeah awesome well thank
you guys so much for joining us I had a
lot of fun will we're back on Friday as
usual the Gatsby is arriving tomorrow
which is a mobility scooter we bought oh
yeah oh I'm very excited so we have a
lot to look forward to on Friday anyway
guys hope you have a great week we'll
see you then Tata thanks for watching
[Music]